good morning Millennials and good
morning counselors Ned good morning
camper good morning counselor Wow rise
and shine
rise and shine I'm so excited to have my
favorite counselor on my web show
Wow who liked iCarly I am iCarly and
finally my favorite counselors here to
see what I do for a living that so I can
afford to go to camp and be your
favorite camper right and we have so
many questions for you coming up during
the show but I won't get to them yet but
I just have to ask you a few questions
this wasn't a good counselor snitch
counselor singe yeah am I your favorite
camper no come on
what's it gonna take for me to be your
favorite camper well the favored camper
is never the one that's annoying it's
one who like hides in the back and
doesn't speak to you and you're like oh
I like you for sure but now we've been
hanging out in the offseason
right and you're on my show right and
maybe if the show goes well and you're
feeling it like I could be your favorite
camper okay yeah but work on okay this
would be major for me you guys anyways
for those of you don't know counselor
snitch snitch on the toast
Margo ashrae little sister of the scenes
welcome to the show Ping's I feel like
I've never heard you say my real name I
know sometimes when you like right Margo
you wrote Margo in your story the other
day and I was like who the hell is that
I know I hesitated too because it's like
who is she but she is you she is me
and without Margo watch I think we
wouldn't have this an inch so that's
true we're happy to have you and her and
all of your different aliases here on
the show today
thanks thank you for having me it's
gonna be such a fun show so many so much
needs to discuss so much so so many
personal anecdotes to sprinkle over the
stream how do you feel on the toast
you're usually a little nervous I'm
usually a little nervous but I'm not
that nervous today because like now I'm
always on it like the snitch cam you're
like now you can see what I look like
with makeup and then when I'm in the
chair you can see what I look like
without makeup you're a series regular
now basically yeah yeah and got bumped
up to full time yeah for like a day
let's not get ahead of our time always
happy to have you as my co-host it
really does make my job easy it's just
like I'm sitting at my table at my new
table with my favorite counselor and
we're just talking about the day's news
right we actually do do this right like
on the regular so and we already talked
about a lot of the stories that we have
for you today so before we get into
everything about my fame
counselor and just you know shooting the
[ __ ] like we always do we are here to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast are you
ready for it I'm ready
dun dun okay this first story is really
so important right now because the new
Carrie Underwood album came out on
Friday but I can't stop talking about it
we've been talking about a lot and we're
gonna give you all of our thoughts but
during her press tour she revealed that
she had three past miscarriages before
her current pregnancy Carrie Underwood
who is pregnant with her second child
says in a new interview she had three
miscarriages over the past two years the
35 year old country star revealed in
August that she and husband Mike Fisher
are expecting a baby who will join Big
Brother Isaiah in April sorry Isaiah .
in April Underwood heard Underwood her
single okay that's a news assault hey
bro Underwood her single cry pretty the
title track of her new album
she told CBS Sunday that that this song
speaks to a lot of things that have
happened in this past year quote here we
go
Oh lawdy 2017 just wasn't how I imagined
it she said I kind of planned that 2017
was you know going to be the year that I
work out new music and I have a baby we
got pregnant early 2017 and it didn't
work out yeah it happens and that was
the thing in the beginning it was like
okay god we know this is just wasn't
your timing and that's all right we will
bounce back and figure out our way
through it
and we got pregnant again in the spring
and didn't work out we got pregnant
again early 2018 and didn't work out so
at that point it was just kind of like
okay like what's the deal what is all of
this and throughout the whole process
you know I'm writing and literally after
right after finding out that I would
lose a baby I'd have a writing session
I'd be like let's go you know I can't
just sit around thinking about this like
I want to work I want to do this so that
makes a lot of her album make a lot of
sense and a lot I was gonna say that now
that I knew that I listened to the album
again and like I didn't get vibes of
like that well it makes cry pretty makes
sense and it makes her whole confusing
past year make sense where she's like in
the public eye but we're not really like
getting up to see her no you gotta makes
total sense cuz we were saying all these
weird stuff is going on and like we knew
something was not right right and now
this makes sense that she came out of it
that makes total sense but regarding the
album I don't know well so we were
talking about the album because we
went to a concert on Saturday night and
we should get into which we need to talk
about we should open with that we went
to the not mera Mars niall horan concert
and we were so excited just like to
Steen's hitting the road and we had a
lot of time to talk about the Carrie
Underwood album in the car because our
uber driver missed the exit and took us
40 minutes out of the way it was just
crazy he was like unlike anything I've
ever seen before like he missed the exit
sometimes you miss the exit that happens
it's okay but the next exit wasn't for
18 months oh thank you 18 miles out of
the way to then come back the 18 months
when we finally found the ATM I likes it
the way that the uber was telling us to
go like you couldn't make that left so
we wound up making a random turn and
going a little bit further I by the way
he could make you could make the left he
just didn't yeah I had a really big
grievance with the uber driver and
Jackie just like was trying to make
excuses for him and I wasn't I wasn't
making excuses for him I said she was
freaking out and I was being like really
calm and I was just like she was like
why are you being so calm I was like
honestly like this kind of stuff happens
to me all the time like and she was like
you know now that I think about it any
time this has happened to me I'm with
you yes she's just like I things like
this just happened to you and so she was
just like remaining so calm and inside I
was like I was being like a backseat
driver like I was like up front and I
was like making sure you made every turn
Jackie I well I was like watching and
making sure we made the fact that exit
that we needed to take and but it might
hard I was just like this is just my
life like of course we leave with an
ample time anti-nerd
and it winds up taking us an hour and
forty-five minutes we get there in the
middle of Mara Marisa said and like she
was amazing I could have used a little
bit more of her totally we only saw
three songs I just we we said it we like
looked up the setlist and I was like
we'll probably just make it for like
second wind which is like what we loved
and it was half way through the set and
we were like pulling up and we hear
second wind and we are running like is
we we didn't make it but we tried we
tried but at least I've seen her before
so like it wasn't a total like satin and
all the songs that we missed we've seen
her perform I think except for the
middle which we saw which we saw and by
the way I meant to say to you when she's
saying my church didn't they feel like
we were at church yeah because the I was
telling you about the venue space we
were at PNC Bank Art Center in Holmdel
New Jersey and it's one of my favorite
that needs even though it's like
a little too far to be going from the
city it's just like 20 minutes too far
if we could like move it up push it up a
little bit guys that'd be great but it's
really like an amphitheater so it has
this echo and it feels like you're in
the church peace I'd like everyone was
just saying like hallelujah yeah like we
were at Hillsong no reason for sure at
Hillsong and I think those kind of
provide with the song but I never
understood that i want to go to Hillsong
and when Carlin's came on the show he
was like and we told I'm a big fan of
Hill songs music me too he was like you
should come like everyone's welcome like
Jews any type of religion whoever you
are just like um and I feel like I would
have a positive experience Oh totally
it's Yom Kippur week like I'm saying she
will well yeah no unless I go tomorrow
so I can repent for it on Wednesday no
but you're supposed to be repenting
these the ten days in between Rosh
Hashanah and Yom Kippur it's like I was
just not good right right that's time
soon this week I don't know I can't tell
if I'm a big sinner or a small Center
and I feel like as life goes on and
becoming a smaller sinner right but I'm
feeling like the sins that I'm
committing might be a little bit no I
think that you're just more aware of
your sins now because you're just more
in tune as opposed to like when you were
younger and you would make more sins you
just didn't realize yeah no but I feel
like now like my sins weigh heavier on
me like the small even though there's
less of them whereas before it's like
ignorance is bliss really right but I'm
saying oh you're way right as I grow up
I'm just like I want to be a better
person you know it's a really hard sin
to stop doing talking about [ __ ] about
people yes honestly to sin that I'm not
willing to give up just not they're such
a big sin like in the jewelry yeah like
mushroom horror like speaking badly but
like we would have to cancel the show
there there would mush I would never
have to open my mouth ever again
no I know and I try like actually I
think on the show no I do not my level
of talking like - like a minimum of like
oh like their shirt ugly as opposed to
like saying something evil and cruel
there's a big difference but like I'm
not ready to just like stop talking
about people yeah maybe and hopefully
I'll get there at some point in my life
well and you talk about people but it's
less shown hard raw so it's like bad
things about right and we do the a show
we talked about people but I feel like I
try to like keep it unless it's someone
that I just can't and chance stand right
who can't I stand
oh right right like right but we don't
become better than that right and if
that's like the worst person I'm talking
about like I feel like they understand
up there yeah so anyways that's really
my like resolution for this year is just
to like work on myself on the inside
definitely talk about [ __ ] I know I can
never stop completely talking [ __ ] cuz I
just like be more aware of what they're
saying you know it's bad yeah and like
feel work like when I do it to feel
badly about it so that like I do it less
you know yeah I've been starting to feel
badly about things more often now that's
good like I'm more aware of things that
I'm doing the first step is acceptance
admitting that you have a problem right
they sound like I'm emitting out of a
problem it's like I do some among whom
maybe should have done that yeah so is
that what's your resolution for this for
this Jewish New Year um I like kind of
want to become a little bit more
religious that's nice like I want to
stop mixing milk and meat I'm not there
yet but I'm getting really close
I feel the coming I feel like that would
be like a big like it wouldn't be very
significant change and it wouldn't be so
hard for you to do right except like the
whole Atkins like I can write but you
only do it in your home anyway and then
do you actually eat at home yeah so I
feel like are you like wait the three
hours or just like no no like I'm fine
like having milk and meat like within
the same hour just like together it
seems so much yeah like she's on a
burger yeah and you don't need it the
burger is good without it right I had a
steak the other night on Friday night we
went to hunt and fish Club and they have
one kosher steak on the menu I know that
comes in like the tin foil it didn't
come in the tin foil so I asked if it
was kosher and they said yes and then
Zac tried it and apparently kosher meat
tastes different if you're a person
everybody tastes better and saltier I'm
pretty sure it depends on the meat like
I think kosher chicken is better then
non kosher chicken but I think not
because your steak might be better than
Coach your steak I don't know I know cuz
I don't need it
but anyway delicious to me and I just I
felt like you know that scene in the
early season of girls when it was
actually good when she like eats meat
for the first time in a while she's like
I can feel myself getting stronger
that's how I felt like I felt myself
like I got to dinner I was like so
hungry and like almost lightheaded and I
could feel myself getting stronger
anyways we went to the concert oh right
every Wow crazy tangent but in the two
hours we listened to the Carrie
Underwood album the Niall Horan album so
we had
really long discussion about the Carrie
Underwood album and it's really good
you're really really into it I'm really
really into it I think it's such an easy
nice list and you don't have to make
yourself like it like I have to do with
a lot of other albums and like yes
there's are some songs that are like why
are you singing this but then there are
some songs like Kingdom that are such
bangers Kingdom is the most beautiful
song on the album I think it's the one
other than cry pretty that really like
speaks to the her mindset right now and
it's just like so beautiful and honest
and of course like there's a choir that
comes in at the end that just actually
something about God but then there are a
few songs on the album that are giving
me like Juliette Barnes Rayna Jaymes
vibes where it's like she's singing
about boys and buses and it's like fake
music right almost and it's giving me
like vibes like this should have been
for Kelsea Ballerini that song
southbound where they hang out like tan
lines and I just feel like I don't know
Carrie Underwood like you've had a
really like emotional crazy year I feel
like there's so many songs like she
wrote that were almost too personal and
didn't put them on the album I couldn't
agree more this she definitely wrote
like a catalogue your favorite word of
songs and like she definitely took some
out and cuz like she just couldn't
handle it which I get but give us like
one right and also like we don't need
like I do your privacy but it's just
there's a there's a couple different
vibes on the album also giving me like
Katy Perry prison vibes where it's like
she's singing about like staying out
like leaving leaving her car at the club
but it's like you're 30-something and I
we know you're not doing that right yeah
it's like songs that were meant for
Ke$ha alright so I'm not getting that
and I know that prism had songs that
were meant for Ke$ha cry pretty has a
couple songs that are meant for count so
everybody is that I love present but
there were a few songs that didn't that
didn't fit so I love this album but
there are a few songs like nope they
just feel like filler and then someone
else wrote them and I feel like Carrie
Underwood's last album called
storyteller was all stories about other
people like you know these situations
all his money could never save Jenny
from the devil living in his I totally
and so here's super the hard though to
now sing about herself especially
because she can barely give an interview
without crying she hasn't seen cry
pretty on tour she has to go on tour
with this album she can't cry at every
show that's true yeah okay fine and I
just I really love her and I know that
we've like had a lot of question marks
about like her personal life and I'm
done
I'm talking about it I'm done
speculating and I'm done insinuating
that's something else deeper darker is
going on because one it is and two it's
none of my business
totally and three she gate she gave us
what she gave us a little bit with the
whole miscarriage thing right and so
like a second time someone asked her a
question she starts crying makes me sad
because what's inside and it's like okay
I'm backing off right and I'm supporting
and listening to your album and we're
gonna go to the concert of course we are
and if you only listen to one song from
the album
it better be Kingdom it's also feels um
it has like a Christian music vibe
because she that's really why we like it
so much great love Christian music and
it's like speaks a lot like about her
faith you know and like it's just so
good like I was listening to the album
on my way home and like I wasn't really
paying attention because it's an easy
listen like you really don't need to
like pay attention to like it right and
I was up to a minute - and at minute -
and eight seconds this choir comes in
and I was like shocked back into the
music I was like wait what am i
listening to and that I saw and then I
like went back to like realest and I was
like holy [ __ ] this is amazing and I
texted Jackie I was like you have to
listen to Kingdom and you have to make
sure to get up to minute two in eight
seconds right I thought you were telling
me that cuz she says a lyric a lot I'm
feeling that benefit like what telling
right but then once you heard today you
would know no it was it was very very
beautiful ah so then we experienced the
concert oh yes we did experienced it
which was really fun we had such a fun
funny time we were just laughing and
like it was a fun concert because I feel
like sometimes when I go to concerts
it's like every song is important to me
and I need to be like present for every
song but like you know I don't know all
of his songs so I was sitting a little
bit I was just enjoying writing there
and it was really fun we had such a fun
time such a fun time the One Direction
fans are so freaking crazy right and
it's like Niall is kind of like the runt
of the litter no way that way LOUIE
LOUIE Tom I would say right you're right
I would say it goes Harry Zayn even
though I hate him
Niall Liam Louie okay I think Niall and
Liam like interchangeable yeah you could
flip them a little bit um but he was so
talented and he really liked he was kind
of so funny because all these girls
they're obviously there for him to play
like drag me down but um he really
thinks of itself as like a rock like a
rock and roll you know like he was
singing group race
and like you can tell that's when he was
like really flourishing totally and we
were like dying to be like yeah
Horan we were at a rock and roll show oh
my god no but he was so cute and when
he's saying drag me down like I lost my
mind but also and I said to Jack because
me and Claudio has the Harry Styles
concert and we were indoors so like the
screams were just elevated to a point
that it made the concert unbearably
unbearable and not fun like I just I
couldn't now I can't even hear my own
thoughts and everyone around me was just
like crying and like they had Harry
Styles as their phone background it's
like I'm a huge Harry style Stan don't
get me wrong but like I'm not crazy and
so I was getting that vibe too but
because we were outside it wasn't nearly
as bad but it's still really ending
about and because it was Nile but it was
still it was piercing and the security
guards were wearing those headphones
that Kiwis managed airplanes well I
thought it was with babies babies and
also like because airplanes are so loud
you have to like wear those headphones
and it reminded me when I watched a
Jonas Brothers concert DVD when the
security guards are talking about like
the piercing loud screams that they
can't that they've never heard levels
before like like I'm at least glad that
these kids are passionate about
something you know when it's something
good that's true and also like it's just
a little weird to me that's like I know
that I'm a huge One Direction fan like
very big but like I've gone to like
Harry's solo tour and Niall solo tour
now like that's a little creepy
but have you ever been to a One
Direction concert no I really want oh
well I mean I'm going where they go back
when they when they come back together
and they go on tour like I will pay
literally every dollar of my savings
that I haven't started saving for and
I'm going I'll be wearing earplugs
because of the screams will be insane
but I'm going like I'm going actually
got a DM but I don't know if it's true
because like everyone lies that
someone's friend like works in a studio
and like they've been in the studio for
like the past couple months but I feel
like a girl in halves would get pictures
of that I don't know I feel like um
celebrities are getting better and
better at hiding maybe or maybe like
they're they have deals with the
paparazzi that like when will give it to
you when it's time when it's time I
don't know man when that day comes just
don't talk to me and what I realized two
things in life one like people who like
paint like
so easy to get free concert tickets like
that I don't ever get my pay for concert
now I feel like a sucker but I will pay
any amount of money to go to like the
concert that I want to go to like
concerts or when I'm my happiest like
I'm always like when I'm like just so
happy in the moment like right I don't
want it to end so I would also you can't
put a price on that feeling and then my
third thing is now my what I want to
start doing is getting merch from every
concert that I go to even if it's just
like a little hat or a keychain just to
remember that I was there cuz we were
talking in the car we've been to so many
concerts and you forget yeah I think so
like because they are my happiest
moments like I want to remember I want
to have like elite maybe just a keychain
from every show like and just collect
them just have a little memory yeah but
that key geumja be a hundred dollars or
so right and we bought big sweatshirts
we didn't even buy but I did wear it all
day yesterday it's actually pretty cute
right and we I saw counselors Nate
wearing jean shorts and a Niall Horan's
Bechet so I gotcha Norton and I have
power and sweatshirt it happened that
was he has a hard name Niall Horan the
Niall Horan's like her [ __ ] her to her
it's like her factor story that was so
funny then wait of course the treachery
never ends there oh let me tell me
actually so we leave in the middle of
the middle of the second-to-last song
and we get an uber and it was so
seamless usually getting an uber thing
he was really hard so we get in our
Mercedes uber X by the way and it's so
easy for us and we should have known we
should have known it was going to be too
easy too easy you actually thought look
he's getting to the city drop to he's
down to do true drop-offs amazing go
home go to sleep enjoy my day on Sunday
and then I get a call from a shaky voice
lovely so I did not move yesterday like
did not move so my just phone call like
6 p.m. and I wanted to go to join Redux
like I wanted something to drink and I'm
like looking at my backpack from the
concert and like my wallet is just not
there and it's just so weird because the
night before like I was laying in bed
before I went to sleep after the concert
was like you should like check to make
sure you have all your stuff I was like
no like pick giver like you have all
your stuff like there's no reason you
wouldn't like go to sleep okay and so I
looked like my bag like good thing that
you didn't because my pit I wouldn't
have gone to sleep no because I would
have been able to reach him right you
would have had to wait yeah so god
that's God anyway so it's not there my
wallet and I I was thinking I was like I
know I
that I had it like sometimes like you're
like mmm I don't know I'm like no no I
know that I did and I'm just thinking
I'm like when was my bag open I paid for
this I paid for that but I knew I put it
back and then I'm like hmm when we were
in the we were home Jackie took her
charging box out of my backpack and like
it must have fallen out not that that
really ever happened but like that's
just what I thought yeah so I call
Jackie with my shaky voice I'm like
Jackie when you aren't sure like we're
placing that stuff is so hard to come by
especially cuz I don't have an ID so I
have to go to the passport office get it
and you only do that so many times I've
already done it twice like I just I the
pit was just ginormous and I realized I
was like I was I do take my charger out
of your bag and luckily like you use I
gave you a little Fendi wallet and I
remember thinking well like this wall it
was so cute wow I'm sorry my sister for
giving it to her and I took my charger
so I was like yes the wallet was in your
bag when I took the charger and it was
definitely entangled so if you lost it
it's in the car right so I get in touch
with the driver via goober which by the
way like we talk a lot of [ __ ] about
Ingrid but they live very good way of
connecting you for your left last night
Emily I couldn't disagree more every
time I've ever lost anything it's taken
me forever to get in contact with them
we just have a lovely great really great
driver he had like even while he was
driving us he had like an iPad
split-screen situation like looking at
all different maps like he was just
really in tune so I gave the lost uber
for my number he calls me immediately
and I was like do you have a wallet in
the car and he was like let me pull over
he was like wow yeah and literally two
people just got out of the car he's like
I've been driving all day and like no
one stole it so he had the wallet but
then the problem was he was a New Jersey
driver he picked us up in Holmdel he was
down the shore like he's not a city
driver so he was like when I come to the
city I will drop it off and anyway he's
long story short he wound up getting a
trip to the city last night and we got
the big five minutes later after that
he's like oh I got a call at UH 15th
Street and I was like oh my god like God
so yeah this is her wallet and like I
just it was all so close book it was a
very treacherous experience but you know
what I usually had a lot of fun that
everything worked out I feel like if I
hadn't out of my wallet I wouldn't be
saying that it was worth it but I'm
unfortunately for my life like I never
like get all the fun with none of the
treads like I was even thinking back to
like some other past experiences where
it's just like always happening like I
just remember that I'm going to the lady
antebellum concert at Jones Beach and I
was so excited we rented a convertible
like literally couldn't wait to hit the
road Jones Beach July like we're gonna
drive there top down and it rained the
whole time like yeah let's just I was
honestly so fun in the rain right but
like you were eating in a little car
with like yeah it was so so small just
for a car like it's just tart yeah
anyways so I just whatever a video and
we got the wallet back so thank you Alai
from uber you are Jackie was so nice
yeah I mean I did pay him but right
whatever
okay next story something we've been
avoiding talking about but you know even
the world is abuzz and these are people
who are in your like category some
people about I actually really enjoy
right whirlwind wedding Justin Bieber
secretly marries Haley Baldwin two
months after proposal say sources okay
this is a little bit of fake news but a
little bit of real news because Justin
Bieber have secretly tied the knot just
two months after getting engaged the
singer on the model were married
Thursday in New York City people
confirms quote they went ahead and did
it without listening to anyone a
religious or spoke to the family and
convert to people that they were legally
married at the courthouse but are going
to have a religious ceremony and
celebration with family and friends soon
they're going to have a big blowout in
front of God and everyone they love the
religious source tells people but no
they just source things just so weird to
me like what's the difference between a
religious source and a regular source I
do not know but Haley Baldwin tweeted
and put it on her in stories because I
understand the speculation but I did not
get married today but did they go down
to do they get they made a married at
the courthouse like did they get their
like their likeness
right but why would she have said that
like I understand why you say that but
I'm not if she like got a marriage
license like I feel like you know also
isn't the marriage license public record
like shouldn't this just be an easy case
to solve
I feel like they got their marriage
license which by the way you do before
your wedding right but no one's like who
they got married and then you get like
you have your wedding and and to them
they're more like religious people than
they are I would say law abiding so I
feel like for them they don't feel
married until it's like in the eyes of
God that could be it but I wouldn't say
they went to the courthouse and got hit
no it's definitely misleading but um
also technically if they did get their
marriage license they are married which
I'm really happy to see because I feel
like all of these engagements never
actually come to fruition yeah and like
what he and I said when all of this was
coming out like just young people really
like you know being crazy and getting
married like it's a nice example of a
set totally I actually really really
like that I'm except he looks crazy but
I'm willing to get past it and I
definitely think there's a little bit of
weirdness going on like between their
whole like things stick whatever but I
really like them so I just don't and
it's a level of weirdness that you just
have to accept like in the celebrity
world they'll never just like be normal
like Jaden get married mean Ottomans
with nothing no strings attached white
picket fence dog one two children one
boy one girl right well honestly Haley
Baldwin like I didn't even know that
Haley bailed him but she like has like
remember how GG did like ggx Tommy
Fashion Show she asked I was adidas
today in London and like is Justin gonna
be there I don't know I think it's
really cool and I'm happy for her I
really like her and I feel like everyone
for some reason hates her and I love her
I think she's so gorgeous like beautiful
and just perfect and like she's finally
getting what she wanted she's one of
Justin Bieber like for ever like good
for her I mean I the weirder looking he
gets the prettier she gets it's like
she's sucking the beauty out of him good
so he stays no and she's been looking
amazing like her whoever her stylist is
like she's just been like looking super
cute really appropriate like for they
just like go down and get ice cream
there at the Seaport a lot to like
always walking around but she like he's
wearing like a normal person clothes but
I've been like totally copying her style
like she's been loving to wear the like
big sweatshirts and like sneakers so
when I was in class the other day I
ordered like three big sweatshirts from
boohoo like pink a pink sweatshirt and
says like girl and like just such cute
things I'm gonna wear it like as a dress
it was sneakers because Haley Baldwin
did it that's really cute I tried that
was kind of like my vibe for cam toast
and then what I realized is like I have
really [ __ ] ugly knees and that's the
only piece of skin you're seeing like I
I just like it's not a good
representation of the rest of my body
so I need like over the knee boots with
a dress oh it's becoming today is
definitely nice season but like the rest
of my outfit has style so you're a
little distracted I mean I don't even
know if anything about my knees so maybe
once I start this I'll realize you know
I
we knew I had bad bad knees like I don't
even want him like it's just not good
like it's just but now like the only
thing is like I don't have to shave my
legs and like it's just something I
don't like to do yeah I hate shaving my
legs do it all the time once you start
you can't my god it's so Harold getting
a wax isn't even a good viable option
because it's like it doesn't work I
don't know I disagree I I like get like
wax as often because I hate I hate
shaving my legs and like they say smooth
for a month really because I gotta like
wax like a year ago and it like it felt
like my hairs were like ripped but they
weren't ripped from the root well maybe
you shouldn't get a good one I know but
I went to the person like wax is
everything else for me it's different
like for my legs like I went to like the
girl who does my manicure like they're
ruthless there and like it doesn't even
really hurt that much and it stays with
like one month and it's great I would
yeah but I wouldn't let them do anywhere
else because they're scary right it
writes right I used to get like my arms
waxed at like nail salons I don't know
why they were really smooth for a day
that was a fun day
then they got like prickly strangeness
anyways once again happy for Justin
Bieber and Haley Baldwin happy that
weird not haven't been talking about
them a lot and happy to continue to
report on anything ok with that
what is that there's a speak do you guys
hear that it sound like a fire so what I
usually for the fire alarm but is there
a fire that would be so crazy
okay yeah derive anything it would be a
drill like imagine that show is over
okay we're checking on it but like oh my
god that gave me such a pig like my face
literally one of my biggest fears is
dying in a fire I think about it all the
time I don't know why like I don't know
why but I always just like I have this I
have an escape route in to escape route
to plan in my head for my apartment of
if there was a fire like where I would
go and how I would get out yeah like I
don't live that high up so like if I had
to jump out like the window like I think
I would make it right but I got a big
ass or maybe I would just like land on
my butt right no do you guys hear that
they definitely hear it
oh they hear it a beep yes you guys yeah
we're sounds like a piano that is true
it's not a fire alarm because it would
continue yeah and they would be
get the [ __ ] out this is the fire
marshal speaking and I feel like it
would be a drill but like don't they
know the most prestigious more alive
don't they know my [ __ ] counselors
here do you think this this is gonna
make me favorite camper oh my god I have
such a pain you do I'm like sweating now
it's like and we only cover two-fifths
of the story like we can't end the show
here like you guys aren't informed yet
right okay okay they're gonna make a
quick announcement there's a fire drill
in the building but we can stay for and
I can't believe this hasn't happened yet
on the Tosun like never happened before
in the past because like corporate
offices have fire drills it's like today
ya know and no one gets up are you Sonny
it's nothing love fight we're about to
be burnt toast fire drill you're welcome
that was a really slow that was really
so good long really painful I hope you
all heard this is a fire show for the
person second floor except for the
morning toast and it's only zero so we
will not be burnt and toast you guys Wow
they said so crazy I didn't know that
was like your biggest fear yeah it's
like something I oddly think about a lot
it's because like I live with Olivia but
she's often not there and so like I just
think about like ways that I could just
like die in the apartment and like no
one would know right but except I guess
if there was a fire people would know
and maybe it's because your room doesn't
have a window that like cuz like right
so I'd have to like really get somewhere
yeah I think I think about it often well
you show something about that when you
move like you should move to like a low
floor and like you might feel safer
truly no it's not that like I think I'm
like gonna just
died in a fire like there's a smoke
alarm like if something happened like
you know it would go off and like yeah
whatever but it's just something that
it's just something that I am that keeps
me up at night among I mean it's crazy
it's like I'm always worried about
leading my iron on you know that that
keeps me up me too and I don't even use
an iron right but it's so quickly like
in apartment buildings like I love the
level of trust that you have with your
neighbors that like they're not gonna
leave their irons on and they're not
gonna like burn down the building no but
like I'm so psychotic like I know like
I'm very like cautious about things I'm
so crazy like I know that I like shut my
door fully like you do have to like just
but like I know that and I do it just
like automatically to have it like
sometimes I just think that I didn't so
I literally call my dorm and I'm like
hey can you just go like check to make
sure my doors shut and like it always is
but it's like I just need them to
relieve me of my pit right so also the
your next apartment like you should have
a door that like slams behind you like
my night so I never even think about
that
yeah I would if I didn't right so now
you know I'm just nuts
yeah I mean we're all nuts I take
pictures of my iron like so that I'm so
that when I'm out and I think to myself
like to leave my iron on I can just look
at my picture and like because even if I
know that I didn't like I will convince
myself that I did like when we were in
the I will convinced myself that when we
were in the him when we were in the
handsome I got out to dinner and I
didn't even wear I wear my hair like
this like not even styled and I
convinced myself that I left my the eye
or not and it was even worse because we
were like in a rental house and Theo was
in the house and I was like oh my god so
much at stake so that's why I like and
we could not enjoy dinner cuz the whole
time
I thought I left my iron on no I gave
myself like pits for absolutely no
reason that's why when the whole wild
thing happened the night before I was
like shut up Margo like you just do this
to yourself right really there was some
there there right and and and I asked to
toast our recommendation on irons that
turn off automatically and I never even
bought one because my piece of [ __ ] well
Olivia always keeps her iron plugged in
in our apartment and like I honestly I
don't care but she said and I trust her
because she's smart that like if you
just shut the light off in the bathroom
like if the electricity is off then the
iron shuts off right but you need that
you need to see oh but I still unplug it
after she ever does but I always do
before I leave because I'm just like you
know what not today not today Satan okay
next story
super cute Sarah Hyland and Wells Adams
celebrate their one-year anniversary so
Sarah highlands posted a picture of her
and wells with actually really cute
caption one year ago today you asked
my you asked to hold my purse when I was
dancing in that moment you took my heart
you then gave me my last first kiss and
in that moment you took my breath away I
love you too Pluto and back Wells Adams
yes Pluto is a planet it always will be
that's funny they're cute and that's a
really cute story like I know they met a
few mutual friends like Brandi Cyrus's
birthday party I'm pretty sure like
Halloween oh yeah except it's not
Halloween yet what's today they met in
September no remember they went public
when they weren't dressing things so
that was Halloween right and I know what
their Halloween custom is this year how
did he know that he told us when he came
on the show because we were like
remarking on how their costume was so
cute and he was like they already knew
so far in advance yeah I mean I feel
like after Halloween I get ideas for
next year or the costume gentleman they
didn't do for I'll tell you after but if
I want to write it down on a piece of
paper will like leave it here and then
after they come out with their custom we
can show you that like we were right but
I would not be the one to spoil
someone's Halloween costume and also if
we do then they won't do it and then we
look like liars and like also they'll
never tell you anything again you learn
again right I want them to know that we
are trustworthy right yes we like come
on here we spill tea but like if you
tell us not to say something we won't
say it right and it's like a Halloween
costume what are you gonna be for
Halloween I have no idea every year I
need to that costume never gets old I
want to wear it all the time I don't
know maybe something like greatest show
men but like I did that for my birthday
so like no but you not even that like a
dress like it but like maybe I've maxed
out that whole theme and also Halloween
is tricky this year because it's it's
like July 4th it's on a Wednesday do we
celebrate the weekend before or that
week and everything before it's wrong to
celebrate Halloween in November
I completely agree we're celebrating the
weekend before so I'm actually gonna be
in Austin for Halloween which is
actually gonna why because they have a
wedding there which is gonna be really
late because like what's that street
called like the six or something Street
it's really crazy it's like Nashville
but even crazier and but I just won't
get to be with my sister so we don't we
can't dress up together that's actually
I've got one plan for Halloween so if
anyone wants to invite me to a party
that'd be great yeah you're a fun gal at
a party yeah so I have coordinate with
Zach we had some cute ideas from last
year still that we didn't do like I
really wanted to be like Annie and Daddy
Warbucks but then like I have to look
ugly yeah that's the worst that's when
it's like a creative costume but like it
warrants you not looking your best so
is it really that great like one if
everyone like looks like sexy and
Halloween I would be wearing like a red
dress in tap shoes and like red curly
hair like oh my god
you know yeah like I'm like II would
have to use your real hair and like go
like banana curls oh my god I would die
right when we when I did those French
braids that cantos and I took them out
and it was like yeah but even worse like
you need it to be even tighter like this
I know right so I don't know if I want
to do that to myself you have another
few others in mind and then I have a
solo mission I want to do myself but um
I would not be looking hot like it's not
hot do I know it um I I guess I could
tell I probably won't do it
Maison Ramsey oh no I imagine me with a
little blonde and I would look like a
little boy like that's not fun going out
looking like not cute is not fun anyways
Welles and Sarah and I really chose a
story like one cuz I thought the caption
was Feud and like he held her purse and
like good for him making a move on sarah
hyland like the highest such moments on
the highest-paid show on TV um but -
you're a big bachelor fan I am I mean
I'm being a bachelor talker I wouldn't
say fan at this point but you watch
everything like Claudia I think much
anymore because like I understand why
but I want to get your pulse on like
what's going on in the bachelor world
Colten season I'm pretty sure has kicked
off yours no but they start filming in
October I feel like yeah so they push it
back I think maybe usually they start in
September I don't know but then why
wasn't he like with all the other
bachelor people at that charity event
this past weekend I don't think he liked
to [ __ ] like that right now that's sure
like maybe he would meet a girl I doubt
it I mean even if he did he wouldn't pay
attention because he's so Thursday so as
of right now you're not going on Colton
season I'm not going on Colton see since
I appreciate everybody really pulling
and gunning for me to go on like I get
it but like no one really cared that
much to like apply me you know right um
but if you had I would probably kill you
because like I would be so freakin
scared like it's just I'm just not I'm
just not ready for that just yet maybe
in like a couple years it's like I'm
sure another another cutie will come
around if I'm still single which
hopefully I'm not then I'll go okay but
it's just like it's just so scary like
girls are so scary without my phone is
so scary like it's nothing happened like
I couldn't call my sisters like I would
just I just
it would be a lot for you mentally but
it's also like a really good like get
rich and famous quick scheme if done
right totally but then like some [ __ ]
would like pull a clip from like this
show one like we're talking about like
me going on and it's like sunny for the
right reason oh yeah I saw her actually
then they'll talk about the morning
toast on ABC not a bad idea actually no
they would be like some podcast yeah
just like a show it's the morning show
okay fair uh to some of the couples from
bachelor in paradise are out here like
living their best lives some are living
their worst Jordan and Jenna right but
you see that Jordan was in Toronto the
whole time and like no one knew no
because he was like in the corner on his
phone toaster saw I know but I'm saying
nobody Utley like like it in tag him I
really feel for him I want him to find a
nice girl like and I feel like he's so
so heartbroken and like right now I feel
like he's like down in Florida like
lifting weights with like tears in his
eyes like that's what he's doing right
now totally know I feel really bad for
him also cuz when me and Claudia like
met him and like went out with him like
I didn't know that he was engaged but
based on the way he was acting I was
like he's totally engaged
he was just like sitting like in the
corner everyone's mean all those girls
were like being so thirsty and thought
he and he was not having it he like got
up and walked away and I was like I
respect you and you're totally engaged
and now just to know that like for him I
really do think it was real it was so
real he said so many times I'm getting
engaged once like I think he was so real
I know he was so real about it I know it
yeah she's such a [ __ ] just she's a
cold-hearted she's a con artist a true
con artist which is so crazy anyways in
happier news Ashton and Kevin are out
here just being so damn I love them I
love them so much I like live for their
snapchats like I don't I don't listen to
anyone's stories with sound odd but I
turn it on but either one of them post
even if it's just like the noise in the
background I want to hear it right
also I turn it on like heavens does a
lot of like Instagram story ads and I'm
like well first of all that's actually
this product sounds great like how can I
get a discount at Sephora and to like he
flips to a shirt and so like I'm
watching it all right but have you
noticed that that one ad every single
bachelor person is done in like the same
day really drop oh I don't watch I
really don't watch a lot of stories
especially not with volume no now it's
they write it and I've just been seeing
it like literally everywhere I think
because I just followed Kevin his story
come up for me like usually if I felt
someone like a month ago like Instagram
knows whether or not I want to watch
their um and anyways I'm just like
loving them I love them so much meet you
I really hope they got engaged and they
were hanging out with Raiden and Adam
and it's just like a bunch of normal
folks right totally in this date and
like they appreciate what they have like
like what they got from The Bachelor but
like they're not thirst monsters and
it's just so nice like they can just
like turn off and go back to real life
as opposed to like trying to like work
it all the time but they can also like
appreciate the opportunities that this
has brought them they can milk it for
all it's worth so that they can be set
up for life totally but they're not like
that thirsty about it like some people
it's like they're so happy they got this
ad and like they're just not like
they're happy but they just don't show
it no no I totally agree
ok next story now into some you know
more newsy news a swimmer is dead after
a shark attack on Cape Cod this story is
really crazy and really sad a swimmer
has died after being bitten by a shark
in the waters of Wellfleet Massachusetts
and what appears to be the state's first
fatal shark attack in more than 80 years
the attack occurred on Saturday near
Newcomb Hollow Beach on Cape Cod
Wellfleet police lieutenant Michael
Hurley told the AEP that the victim was
a man in his mid-20s but his identity
has not been discovered Massachusetts
last shark attack was feed fatality was
in 1936 according to a report by NPR
members stationed WBUR the Cape Cod
District Attorney's Office and the
Massachusetts State Police are both
investigating hardly said I think now
the person has been identified this is
an old story um and it's not updated but
damn that said so many people go to Cape
Cod and like swimming go to the beach
and now knowing that they are
shark-infested waters every one of my
biggest fears is a shark like truly
whenever I'm watching a movie and
someone's in the water like even if it
could be the most a comedy I'm like oh
they're gonna die like a shark he's
gonna shark he's gonna bite them like
it's so scary I will never go that deep
into the ocean like it's frightening Joe
how scary that must be when it's
happening yeah cuz you always like know
before like 10 seconds before there's a
shark swarming those 10 seconds oh my
god I can that makes me so sad I can't
leave it to first one since 1936 which
is really crazy that just means it was
like just on a like unavoidable like
they just right you know right like
there's no shark warnings and the shark
just like he might have gotten lost
right and now it's like you know those
um there's like
that's saying like you have less of a
chance of like dying from a shark thing
that like something else like how it
like never happens but you know what
that just dispels all that for me even
if it does never happen because it's
just so freakin scary it's so freakin
scary a shark like that I just can't and
you know what I think not there's really
like no body of water that you can swim
in without like some sort of anxiety
because like in a pool it's like dirty
chlorine pee like it's just not no I
mean when I graduate I'm never scared I
never know that's here but it's like
it's not just purely enjoyable cuz it's
just like it's chemicals and it's pee
and it's you know not clean and then
like you go into the ocean it's like
either a jellyfish or a shark like you
always just have to like you're always
just worried and then like a lake is
like brown and dirty and gross you know
you can't ever just enjoy I yeah I
couldn't agree more except like there I
was acceptable like there are like a
nice lakes are there yeah I mean like
because like YouTube's water like that
didn't scare me ever that's the ocean
that's where shark could be right but
it's so clear that you'll see it coming
so it even worse yeah now you stop okay
I'm getting a plate now asking about
sharks water a shark what would you do
in that situation I think I would just
like just let go and I thought I would
go Lynn I would say my prayers and I
would just hope that he bit me in a
place that it was painless I just died
instantly but I'm not like suffering and
bleeding out oh my god like that it's
just that it's so sad and so scary it
makes me just so sad you know a movie
like fully justice guarded me about
sharks forever of course I do I don't
know what it's all surfer yes and like I
don't suppose be inspiring yeah yeah he
was supposed to be inspiring which it
was but it still now made me just always
think about sharks in the world was
weird about that movie and I don't know
if this is what happened that I go to
schools annasophia robb and she was in
my class last semester and you didn't
make a friendship she by the way she
didn't come to class me semester started
end of January she didn't come to class
until April I don't like turned to a
girl like annasophia robb and she like
yeah she came to like one class once and
never has come back until today so why
can't you do that then and be at your
job totally oh my god
like what did she say like I just don't
get it she never came and also like that
class they took attendance every single
day there were so many assignments like
shouldn't even come for like the test
like the midterm but she came to the
final the whole thing made no sense I
was really tracking her movements but
like why can't I say to say that like I
had missing a lot of class for Claudia's
tour like when I go with her and like I
like I had a pit the entire week
thinking about the fact that I had to
like tell like my teachers and not even
my teachers my TAS that I'd be missing
like recitation and I said I'm like high
like I worked for a comedian and like
like I'd like make it sound so legit and
like yeah like they like didn't care but
they weren't like that nice about it
like there's still stuff I have to make
up for it but so many famous people go
to NYU like I know I'm not famous fast
wins what they I mean they actually
think they way they went because they
weren't working at it like dylan sprouse
was the president of the dorm that i
lived in my freshman year obviously not
at the same time but like they were
really really involved and I think they
went to everything because they weren't
working
I understand wait someone wrote the
funniest comment they were like you're
gonna give yourself an anxiety attack
like on the show all we're talking about
is the stuff that like that scares us to
death yeah so this is the this is the
episode about anxiety about your biggest
fears also do you watch any of those
movies like the Meg the shallow okay and
I know you love like lightly so he
watches oh I watch the shells because I
love Blake Lively she was like in such
good shape right I was like holy [ __ ]
okay not worth it like I was watching it
and like I really don't like get that
scared that often I mean I do clearly
but like from movies because it's
usually unrealistic but like I was
jumping off of my bed just like running
in place freaking out like I couldn't
watch it I kept like I think most of the
movie I didn't even watch because I was
just like I was just like that the whole
time but oh my god like it was
frightening
it was literally two hours of her on
Iraq trying to like escape the shark and
it's like I can do that for ten minutes
like not when it's like when it's like
just the climax of the movie no no no
the whole movie she's on this rock like
and the shark keeps just like circling
and like yeah and I'm oh my god it was
so scary but no I would never see the
mag I only watch that movie because of
Blake not because I liked rights always
there's a Blake and amazing suit but
yeah okay fifth and final story really
exciting I didn't know this was
with space axes to name the first space
tourists Elon Musk's space exploration
company SpaceX is about to send its
first private citizen into space the
identity of the passenger who will be
the first to hitch a ride on SpaceX big
Falcon rocket for a trip around the moon
will be revealed on Monday and a live
stream the company said that's today a
live stream do you think it's on the
morning to guys meaning I'm going a deep
for the launch has not been announced
nor has the cost of the fight that is
just so crazy like a private citizen a
person just like you and me is going
into space like one why what are the
qualifications like why why then why now
why this firm and I heard rumors that
it's you it is you confirm or deny I can
cover I'm just kidding I can deny you
just wanna know I don't speak I don't
have 20/20 vision do you need 20/20
vision
I know astronauts needed 20/20 maybe
like he changed the game yeah that's
like oh because most people like don't
have 20 like everyone I know wears
glasses or contacts except for me maybe
they change that Madhu's back in the day
maybe I should be an astronaut geez
20/20 vision I I mean I've never needed
even a smidge of glasses you like wake
up and you can just see yeah that's so
crazy because this morning my glasses
fell waking up that's hard see my
glasses fell off my bed and so like I
was like like with my flashlight trying
to find that I can't even tell you how
sad like this thought anytime there are
glasses on the floor like that it's just
the saddest thing cause like they just
knocked off and like I just couldn't
find them no that whole concept like not
be like it's just so far into the whole
concept of waking up and having sight is
so far it is so crazy and don't you you
said you want LASIK surgery yeah like
I'm gonna wait like are nominating your
life I'm gonna get it a hundred percent
I think it's literally life-changing is
just like not yet like I'm just not in
the mood to like you know do that and
you should wait till your eyes get as
bad as they're gonna get yeah they're
pretty bad but um cuz zach has LASIK I
know once like I think maybe he was like
two years ago I was like wow I really
want LASIK and I made a reminder in my
phone for like February 2018 being like
you want LASIK for your 21st birthday
because I remember you said that so I
got the notification this February and I
was like [ __ ] no I don't like I do but
like nothing my 21st birthday right so
in time it was his 50th birthday
Zefram smooches you're so young and cute
clueless oh I mean I saw that a bunch of
times right but it didn't like it didn't
stay out - you understand uh what was
I'm so glad that Zack got LASIK because
I can't lie like you guys in your
contacts your crusty ass contacts laying
around the sink like I can't and I
shan't and I want looks it would be cute
to like see Zack wearing glasses but
maybe I'll just get him some things some
classes some flashes glasses what I was
gonna say one more thing about you and
your LASIK and your 20 oh did you see
that meme about that girl who said a
calendar reminder like for a wedding and
she was like trying to figure out whose
wedding it was like she couldn't figure
it out and she then she realized like it
was her she set the reminder for herself
like that was when she wanted to be
married oh my god that's sad was she no
really funny okay now we're gonna take
some questions for you like spicing in
some personal questions from me and this
questions from the toasters so counselor
snitch counselor snitch am I your
favorite camper yet you're getting there
I'm getting there
okay Jenny OTT stop wants to know
counselor cinch I'm not your favorite
toaster who's your favorite toaster I
know it's not her but who is your
favorite toaster you can rattle off a
few names
[Music]
um-hmm and you met some great ones a
cantos I really do love like the
classics like Lauren no score at all
Renee's watching today Miranda Mae brown
yeah yeah ally week so we didn't I never
even got your pulse how was your
experience at campus it was crazily Oh
Ally
it was crazy like it was just wild I
liked it I just couldn't believe it like
it's so weird that we were at camp like
our camp and then it was just like that
we were drinking and like I've never
seen people doing so much in my whole
life I could just didn't like I thought
I drink a lot and like just I don't
apparently but no and it was so fun and
it was just like so crazy to see like
what you guys did
I'm like we're gonna do it again and
we're gonna are you excited I am
I don't excited for it to be nice out
because the rain was really killing my
right eye ruin so many nice sneakers oh
my god seem like I'm my new workout
sneakers that like I love my EP I was
like are like it's dirty now but
apparently I can just throw them in the
launch yeah bye all birds you can throw
in the wash
like I have yet to do it you know I mean
because I'm scared and because like I
don't wear them aside from camp toast
and it's been a while sweetie since we
took your pulse on your new position
here hmm
this niche term this niche cam the
intern snitch how was it going like be
honest like what are your thoughts on
your job oh I mean it's great like this
is a dream job it's a dream job aside
that like I do have to wake up very
early and like it's just it's been quite
the turnaround for me because since I
got home from Israel I started working
for the toast and so I've been waking up
at 8:00 every single day because the
days now that I don't work for the toast
I have a 9:30 class which is why I don't
work for the Trostle I'm waking up every
day at 8:00 and like if you know me
that's just like not my thing like the
earliest class I've ever taken is 11:00
like I like my sleep but now I'm up
every day at 8:00 and it's just like
I've just been appreciating my bed so
much I used to think like oh wow I love
sleep and like I love breasts but now I
get into bed I'm like holy [ __ ] this is
incredible like yeah and now it's but
it's kind of works in the opposite wakes
like I literally never leave my bed now
like I can't tell you the last time I
went out just because like just not
worth it when I can just lie in my bed
do you know what I mean I totally
totally agree and like waking up like
every day like really makes you
appreciate like the weekends like now I
sleep so late on the weekends I god I
sleep till 1:00 when I could like I so I
stopped off hours Friday and Saturday
night right and after camp toast like I
slept like on Rosh Hashanah oh my god i
legit slept 13 hours it was incredible
yeah me too I think I think it's not 12
yeah like it's just it's just
game-changing but now I'm glad that I'm
doing it because now I'm training my
body to be able to wake up and eat and
you're being so productive because
you're a student you have a job like
I'll be working I'm working people
morning by the way I've never I can't
think about that again I've never been
so busy in my life like I always have
something going on I got a freaking plan
or guys you guys I got a planner I have
so many dates that I have to keep track
of like with like this stuff and then
also with Claudia's tour and then with
school and like due dates and they like
everything obviously falls into one
another and I just couldn't keep track
so I got a planner because I was doing
it in my calendar on my phone like
that's just not conducive and it's not
good enough so I brought it with me and
I'm gonna do it during my class today
cuz like you could do it when you come
over after at my table no I've been
saving it for like when I'm in class
it'll make a lot of time to go by got it
well okay that's very I also have a
couple other like housekeeping stuff if
you want to help with if you're looking
for things to do during class it's fun
to stuff don't find that I get it
oh my god you getting a planner like
just like this family like I'm just so
proud it's so cute it's pink and marbled
I want to see it I'll show you and it's
like small and then it's so cute right
and now like no one can ride you you
also have two jobs cuz you also work for
Claudia's show yeah no one can ride me
tell us a little bit about that
experience going on the road you're a
roadie
it's honestly really crazy like I
thought it would be like so fun like we
go like yeah it's fun cuz like I love to
hang out Claud but it's like it's so
much freaking work and it's like every
time I get back I'm just like I'm dead
and like I I don't even do the show and
so I can't I don't know how she does it
like how she does two shows in a night
like I'm tired just by producing it and
like I really don't even have to like do
that much it's just like by being there
and like breathing but I think it's hard
you guys it's just like it's it's a lot
and like I'm happy to do it like I'm
happy to help and like I'd like it's fun
and it's like memories but it's it's not
that it's not an easy job no it's not
and you're doing a great job at it thank
you and with minimal complaining which
is like the biggest part because I feel
bad complaining cuz like she's a lot of
complaining cuz like she's standing
right there like for hours right we have
a lot of questions about your personal
life okay and you are single yes I am we
actually had a really interesting
conversation about this in my car that
wasn't last night on the way to the
concert because obviously we just had so
much time to chat we were talking about
just dating in general we're talking
that dating apps because I'm a big
supporter of people getting on dating
apps I think it is the way to meet
people these days like I understand that
it's not ideal and it's not how like
most people thought they would find
their person but it just times are
changing like guys just don't approach
girls anymore right and so two of my
friends Dana and Rebecca they weren't on
apps I got dick I'm patron episode we
talked about how I made Dana go on a
dating app she matched with a guy who
she had gone on a date with two years
prior they went out and they've been
needing ever since and what's crazy is
the day that they went out was actually
the two like three year anniversary of
the time that they went out the first
time so that clearly their anniversary
so she went out she's dating like the
first guy that she went out with and
then Rebecca I made her get on the apps
right before Memorial Day week week and
I remember we were at so house and I was
like you've got to do it cuz she's like
someone she was like I want to meet
someone else she's so personable she's
like is so googly and that just means
like she's outgoing like she's not
awkward like she's someone who wouldn't
I'm out and I'm like you're great but
the people that you want to meet are on
apps yeah I mean it's not about you
meeting you being out there it's about
the people the pool so she went on and
she went on a date and she is now dating
the first person she went on a date
that's so crazy so I think it also has
to do with like me and and me also like
pumping people you know getting them
ready for dating up because you
shouldn't go on if you're not ready yet
and we were talking about like if you
should go on one I personally thought
you shouldn't go on one until you were
21 because it's weird to like go on
dates and like Heidi and like you have
to tell the deep person like I'm 20 so
like can we go somewhere that's like
leaning in or like oh my god like that
is Pittsville that's you that takes all
the fun out of it but you were saying
you don't want to go on until I graduate
just say I'm like not ready to like be
on a dating app and like just like talk
to strangers and like then like go on a
date with someone like I don't know like
I'll get there like trust me but like I
just want to get myself like one more
year of like maybe it'll just fall into
my lap and if it doesn't that's fine
and I like I like save my friends and I
think a bunch of us were like when we
graduate it's just like feels weird to
like be going on apps and like I'm in
class do you know what I mean it's just
a little odd to me but like I'm gonna do
it if I have to and like I'm totally
open to it just like not yet which app
would you go on probably hinge because I
feel like everyone meets on hinge or
like maybe like Jace white ya know
Shalini and Zak yeah they met on they
met on Jamie's Jace like Nathan one of
the two one of the two like all are good
I'm not gonna go in like 800 apps like
I'm not there yet didn't you spell your
self too thin and then you don't check
them all and then you're like I remember
when I like before I met Zach I was on a
couple different apps but I'd been on
the apps for a while because I was like
oh way single and then I was like I was
going I would be like taking the subway
to work and stuff and I would like see
like guys and I'm like
have we met time and I felt like I was
becoming like hinge famous oh [ __ ] like
I felt like everyone had seen my profile
already like okay so that was not it's
not you the one that it's like you match
with people that you're not friends with
but you have mutual friends with yeah
it's based on mutual friends on Facebook
but I feel like they should also match
you with some Facebook friends that you
don't interact with right because like
they could like also just like a million
freaking people on because you're
looking you can match with your face
friends on hinge I feel like I did at
certain points so fine so so that's it I
feel like hinges for you and they
changed the the way it works since I was
on I think you only get a few matches a
day now whereas he used to get unlimited
but I also think that's better because
like cream like they get the cream of
the crop yeah and like you don't you
shouldn't you should go on every day
check your matches well you shouldn't be
able to just go on like do a ton and
then you don't come back for a while
right that'll be so fun the day that I
make you I set up my hinge because that
was like me to a Facebook I remember
that day we were in detail and I
friended and I gotta get it i friended
everyone like people older than me
that's like risky to like friend like I
didn't care I was like a friend and
friended and then I got that thing it's
like you've maxed out like your friend
requests for the day like come back in
24 hours and I was like okay that was
just such a fun fun day yeah we like had
a photo shoot at the Hilton in Tel Aviv
do you still my favorite picture of me
ever
always works we're gonna do the same
when you have a hinge and then your bio
would be like councillor Finch no it
can't be like people wouldn't get it yet
it has to be like super normal speech is
hard for us speaking of snitch house
body by snitch going she's been better
she hasn't really posted in a month but
like I do story sometimes but like I'm
not I like the past like week I've been
getting back into like my workout grind
so what she's coming back I've been
really busy also like the past three
months I've just been like eating
whatever I wanted and like I it which is
fine but like now it's just time I need
to like cleanse myself and get back into
it you like she's coming back slowly but
surely give her some time but yeah I'm
excited
we're also we're going to SoulCycle
together tonight yes my favorite class
musical monday musical monday I need to
start but you need to start working me
out more too because I saw your last
picture was us at Rumble yeah which was
a month ago but I taking you back to in
right I feel like a good goal for me is
one Rumble a week okay yeah do that
I don't know if my body can handle my
more than that my goal is to like I work
out like four times a week but like it's
just not happening like it's right now
I'm at like 2:00 and then also you could
put on your list of when you move like
things that you need a building with the
gym I feel like that would really help
you
that would be healthier a gym a good
mirror yeah but like I like a nice gyms
you don't I mean like it matters oh wait
I agree
like when it's like three machines I
can't I would she have a nice gym in my
building you should come use it but
Claudia said the same thing to me about
her old buildings like if I'm gonna go
to your gym I can also just go to bed
why you J right except I see people
there and it's like actually she might
think like that'd be a good place to
meet someone there's some like it's like
a young and Bill true okay cool cool
I'll give you the keys you can just go
anyways I think that's all we have for
you today finally a show that we kept to
an hour this past week has been crazy
this coming week is gonna be crazy let
me give you the rundown a little bit
tomorrow
I will be joined by Lauren Elizabeth to
help me co-host the show I'm so excited
she's like a true Pro she has so many
exciting projects coming I know if you
want to get her to like send this and
she said she sent me stuff I have to
check my my mail cuz if it's here I'm
gonna wear it on the show tomorrow and
I'll give some to a sister I hope a
sister actually looks or stuff it's
really cute then Wednesday as we've been
discussing and reading but also looking
forward to is the holy holiday of Yom
Kippur I'm actually really excited I
feel like I need it like I just need to
like not be on my phone cleanse repent
for my sins
you know I need like a mental spiritual
cleansing me too like also and then
we're the furthest away from Yom Kippur
that will ever be also I was just so
excited because we've been on Atkins but
like you can't not have a bagel for
break fast so I'm gonna have a bangle
for make fast like I'm already plating I
have okay so I'm gonna have one bagel
one half is gonna be just tuned I love
tuned on a bagel bagel assess me toasted
yes to how crisp brown brown burnt toast
yes and then the other half it's gonna
be cream cheese and lox on the in tomato
like the works on a sesame baked on a
sesame bak and then depending on how
hungry I am maybe like I'll do another
half or maybe I'll just like have like
some Israeli salad and tuna I don't know
but that's like for sure the meal that
I'll be having and then like I'll
probably end up having works no me I'll
be starving but I'm just so excited I'm
like dreaming about it now
no I'm so excited I'm having the exact
same thing as you except on an
everything bagel bagel lightly toasted
and then I won't be having another half
of bagel that is cinnamon raisin not
toasted with bisque off cookie butter on
top and it is just the most delicious
thing I could ever eat
that's like my desert bagel then I will
feel satisfied but that's also like
having one-and-a-half bagels as you're
talking about it it's not great but like
it's still what it's not it's not like
you like our eating right so much I
don't worry sticking to that is what's
hard I know because like will be story
right and you just have to eat slow is I
know I always eat like I'm like like I
haven't seen food in 24 hours right and
then your stomach hurts when you eat
like you fast after you fast then on
Thursday we will be back we will be
joined by Lee Anne Lakhan and 90% sure
Lauren Bushnell as well above her I
won't be here and I'm upset honestly
honestly need you thank you probably in
this class I think you need to come
because it's we actually need an intern
that day it's a lot to handle
like those two classes I can just have
someone sign me and I know people yeah
and then Friday is another big day we
are joined by Jerry O'Connell Friday
definitely can oh okay but it's only one
guess like we can manage it Jerry
O'Connell will be joining us to talk
about play-by-play on Bravo and I'm just
so excited I can't we forgetting Jerry
O'Connell like for some reason I feel
like he's like so famous like not even
like right now just like in life no good
things that he's done super accomplished
yeah it's just like so crazy like Jerry
O'Connell ice cream this chair oh my god
yeah asking about that you have to ask
about that about like Emma Roberts all
of it oh my god I missed Queen so much I
know you should read have a day I know
weekend but we also have to watch the
senator may be on Yom Kippur we need we
need we need shows right we don't need
technology but the only thing we won't
give up is TV right like all right it
gets me through the holiday I have to
get through the day but we don't use our
phones so if you're like looking for us
we will be there you won't be there
we'll see you on Wednesday night after
the Sun Goes Down and after we have our
one-and-a-half bagels counselor snitch
thank you so much for you so much for
having me we're just a pro per usual you
just knocked it out of the park and we
will be back tomorrow with another fun
day of the morning toast where can
everyone follow you and everybody on
becoming the best snitch that you can be
even though you're perfect just the way
you are counselor sage and I love you
you can follow me at Marga sure I like
my name just not like two O's just one
and then Balian brilliant inspired a
creative genius and then body by snitch
which is she's in a bowl but she'll come
back so you're gonna want to be there
for
and yeah that's all she wrote that's all
- are all so happy anniversary
to Claudia and bed that is why they're
not here today because they're on their
anniversary vacation they look like
they're having such a great time such
that they both look so good and tan and
just like cuteness ever seen skinny and
skinny like must be nice and I just hope
they're having the best time we love you
guys and we hope you're enjoying and
we're so happy to hold down the fort for
you while you go enjoy being you know
taking a little time off young and fun
and thriving young fun and thriving and
like even though Theo is the most
amazing person in the world like you
know sometimes mom and dad need a little
alone totally and he loves camp he loves
he loves camp
so everyone's happy in the race-off our
household totally good bye everyone see
you tomorrow
I'm Jackie Oh problems you can always
follow me don't worry about it just go
ahead and follow I won't be upset
you